he gestured at me just as i was holding
the phone trying to get through to the
office in london
uh with his gun and he cocked his
kalashnikov in very aggressive fashion
and uh waved it at me and it was pretty
clear that what he was intending to do
or threatening to do
was wait until i was on the phone to the
office and then he was going to either
fire the gun
right beside me or belt me in the face
with a gun or something
[Music]
the piracy had been going on in the gulf
of eden ever since the late 90s
what they used to do was they would
hijack the ship and they would
effectively steal the ship's crew
if you like they would take the crew
hostage and hopefully extract a ransom
my photographer colleague and i were
sent
to somalia to do some reporting on the
ground about
to really just try and find out a bit
about how the pirates operated
we went to a town called basasso which
is on the northern somali coast
uh and um that was a place where you
could see a lot of pirate money
coming in um you see people driving
around in brand new suvs
big new villas going up in what is
otherwise a very very poor part of the
world
i also knew it was it could be a
dangerous place for westerners to visit
as a westerner you stand out there's not
many foreigners in somalia
and uh what you tend to do is to stop
yourself getting kidnapped
is you hire a group of bodyguards you
pay them about
20 bucks a day each and they carry
kalashnikov each you have seven or eight
of them
and they follow you around and the idea
is that they just deter
anyone really from making any kind of
attempt
to kidnap you can you tell me how they
kidnapped you
yeah well on the very last day we
suddenly got a different bunch of
bodyguards
that all the bodyguards had to do was to
drive us to the airport
um so we thought fine um
we drove off and uh we were in um
one pickup truck and the bodyguards were
sitting in the back of another pickup
truck
all of a sudden as we were driving
through one of the outskirts of town
the bodyguard's pickup truck shot in
front of our vehicle
and uh forced our vehicle to halt and
a couple of the bodyguards jumped out
waving their guns and
shouting then the bodyguards ran towards
our car pulled the doors open
and ordered both me and my colleague out
at gunpoint and at that point i realized
i was getting kidnapped
they dragged us over into their pickup
truck
they stuck us in the front cabin and
then we drove off
at top speed out of the town and
into a desert area the car
drove across the desert for about 40
minutes
and then drove up into the foothills of
a
range of mountains uh we got to a point
where the car could drive no further
just at the top of a gravel track and we
were ordered out of the car
um and just they said right start
marching up this track up a canyon
it was a very very empty area um
i couldn't didn't see another soul
anywhere around
at one point we stopped after about a
mile
in a clearing and uh um
i remember one of the one of the guys
looking at me and
earlier on when i hadn't been walking
fast enough he'd sort of
pointed the gun at me and like you know
as if to say if you don't keep walking
you're gonna get a bullet in your head
um and so when we stopped at this point
i thought
maybe maybe they're just gonna kill us
maybe this isn't a kidnapping
uh and one of the kidnappers reached
into a bag
that he had over his shoulder and uh to
my surprise
he pulled out a um a few mars bars
and um some uh bottles of drinking water
and he said yeah drink drink or whatever
and it was at that point we realized
that
they were going to keep us alive
although we had no idea what they were
going to do with us
can you tell me what your day-to-day
life was like
well it really was like pretty much like
living like a stone age man we had
no tv no books to read we weren't
allowed to
use a paper and pencil or anything like
that so there was very little way to
spend the time
then the food we had we ate goat meat
freshly cooked goat and
rice each day that was pretty much it
for um breakfast lunch and dinner
and then we had nothing for um uh you
know going to the
you you go to the bathroom with a tool
uh they recommended using a stick to
wipe your rear end with which
no no a stone which i didn't really
fancy
so you just use your hand unfortunately
and a bit of water but this was the same
water that you haven't
used to drink with we were guarded all
times by
about eight to a dozen guards in fact
they were a very disciplined bunch it
was like being kidnapped by an
army unit of some sort well i had no
reason to believe that they were but
they were
extremely disciplined in everything they
did what was your relationship like with
your captors
and one of the things they say is try
and form a relationship a bit of a
rapport
with the kidnappers um the idea being
that that will make it
more difficult for them to kill you so i
remember
about three or four days into the
kidnapping
we hadn't really spoken to the
kidnappers much at that point
and um they they didn't speak any
english really i didn't speak any somali
um the only language we had in common
was arabic i have
i speak a few words of arabic and they
spoke a few too so that was kind of how
we
communicated and um on about day three
or four
one of the guys a young guy called
faisal he came up to us and he pointed
at me and he said
you from where you and uh so i said i'm
i thought i'll just be honest so i said
i'm from britain uh
and he went ah britain britain good
david beckham
paul scholes manchester united uh tierra
yori
and i thought oh wow you know the
international language of football
um spoken even here in the mountains of
somalia
but it gave us all a bit of a laugh it
made you realize how strange the
situation was
about four or five days into the
kidnapping
we were led to the top of a mountain
near the cave where the kidnappers were
able to get a
reception on their mobile phone and
they told us to call my office in london
which i duly did one of the kidnappers
um
a guy we used to call the old
because he didn't like us and he was old
um
he uh he gestured at me just as i was
holding the the phone trying to get
through to the office in london
uh with his gun and he told me come and
he
gestured as if to say come and sit at my
you know just in front of me because he
was standing just a few feet away
um uh and he cocked his kalashnikov in
very aggressive fashion
and uh waved it at me and it was pretty
clear that what he was intending to do
or threatening to do
uh was wait until i was on the phone to
the office and then he was going to
either fire the gun
right beside me or belt me in the face
with a gun or something or do something
so that when i was on the phone to the
office i'd be screaming like
do what you gotta do to get these people
out to get these people off me to get me
out of here you know
or whatever and that was a pretty scary
moment
the other kidnappers at that point
actually dragged him away from me
and they dragged him down the mountain
aside and i just ignored him i sat where
i was and
they um i got through the office and i
just said look we've been kidnapped but
we are still alive
um and we're not being mistreated we're
being held in a cave in
uh into some mountains somewhere but
that was a big relief to everybody back
home because until that point they had
no idea
or they had no certainty that we were
still alive but i remember from that
moment onwards being pretty scared of
him
and thinking like you know these guys
might start torturing us
uh if they wanted to and that was
that that made me that put the fear of
god in me a lot
whilst you were being held hostage did
they ever make any threats
to sell you they did at one point
threaten to sell us to another pirate
gang
who were operating further down the
coast one morning
um a couple of guys who
were clearly not from the the gang that
was holding us
uh turned up at the cave there was a bit
of conversation
in somali so we didn't know what was
going on but we could tell it wasn't
friendly and then all of a sudden the
commotion
uh broke out and uh our guys started
pushing
these two visitors out of the cave and
someone at that point pulled a handgun i
don't know who it was whether it was a
lot or the
other lot um and fired it into the
ceiling of the cave
this bullet i remember it bounced
several times off the walls and
creased the mat on which my colleague
and i were sitting
outside we couldn't see what was going
on but we could hear gunfire
these two guys who had been kicked out
suddenly reappeared on a distant cliff
edge that overlooked our cave
um with a couple of their colleagues and
they started
firing down into our cave with their own
guns
it was like being in a some wild west
movies bullets pinging around
all this sort of thing um to make
matters worse
um uh one of the kidnappers who was with
us
then decided that we would be safer if
we were actually hidden behind some
rocks
outside of the cave there was a big pile
of boulders there
so uh he got a big machine gun uh with a
bullet belt
that he wrapped around his shoulders
looking like rambo and said right come
on
out this way so we followed him out and
um
uh he hid us behind these boulders and
um
uh said like lie down in that space
there
unfortunately this this set of boulders
was also the place that we'd been using
for the last couple of weeks
as our main toilet area you know i've
got a choice here
either um lie down and in a pool of my
own
sort of piss or keep my head up and just
getting it shut off
um i think it's fair to say that was a
kind of that was a low point in the
whole thing with a
pirate putting a price on your head at
one point they asked for money for us
they asked for three million dollars
each
they told the kidnappers that as
we were journalists there was no way
they were going to pay any money for us
um
and that uh you know we were there to
write about
the problems that were going on in
somalia at the time
and that you know if uh
people kept on getting kit foreigners
who
visited the country kept on getting
kidnapped that would only make somalia's
problems worse
can you explain how you were eventually
freed after
six weeks in captivity we were told
by the kidnappers that we were finally
going to be freed
we weren't told why we were getting
freed uh we got a phone call from london
saying um tomorrow morning you will be
taken to a rendezvous point
elsewhere in the mountains and you will
be met
by a group of
somali clan leaders who have agreed to
act as go-betweens in the situation and
you will be handed over
to them there was about 50 guys
uh there um all armed to the teeth with
rocket-propelled grenades belt-fed
machine guns
anti-aircraft guns mounted on the back
of pickup trucks
it's a small army we were driven up
um over a mountain pass um where we
stopped
and told to get out the car and then we
looked down
into this valley and at the bottom of
the valley we could see
um several other cars um driven clearly
by these
um clan intermediaries also we were told
and the kidnappers pointed to a path
that was leading down to the bottom of
this
mountain pass and they said walk down
there with your hands up and
don't make any silly moves we'll be
right behind you
um so we julie walked down this path
hands up like this expecting to hear
bullets suddenly erupting at any minute
or
and that the whole thing would end in
disaster uh
we julie got down at the bottom and um
we were handed over and uh one of these
um somali elders um uh
sort of elderly man in a suit he said ah
you know
welcome you are now free i remember
there was a moment when we were handed
over to the uh the clan elder
i turned around and i looked at the the
lead kidnapper and i thought
what are you supposed to say or do in
this situation you know are you supposed
to sort of
um uh tell them
or something like that and you know hope
that you'll see him in court one day
or do you sort of say well actually you
know you didn't mistreat us too much
um he was actually quite professional
about the whole thing
maybe shake his hand no i don't think so
um
and just as i was making up my mind
wondering whether to just kind of
nod farewell he turned away and marched
up the hill anyway without so much as a
second glance
do you feel any anger towards them i
feel anger towards them about
you know what they put my family through
which was hell for some people it's seen
as really the only way of making a
living
but on the other hand i met many somalis
um
when i was that out there before we were
kidnapped who were saying look we are
really worried about this piracy thing
because
we have a generation of young men who
are growing up thinking that kidnapping
and hostage-taking
are the only way uh to lead a to make a
living
and uh you know that that is no future
for our country
i was actually out having dinner um with
some friends and
um i got a phone call from my dad and um
we have an agreement where that if you
ring once you're just calling for a chat
you ring twice or more then i know
there's something wrong and i need to
actually stop what i'm doing so
the phone was ringing and i answered the
phone and i heard his voice and i just
said straight away like
who's died